[Music]
um
nancy andy knew something was wrong when
her husband woke up with a fever one
july morning
[Music]
quarantined in the hospital
a couple of weeks later he was gone
so did i just say goodbye um
did i do
last video
i do
okay
for me
that's done
[Music]
[Music]
hani was a chief technician at st
microelectronics facility in muar
the french italian chip maker supplies
to apple tesla and auto components
companies like continental ag
nancy believes that her husband was
infected at the plant the health
ministry confirmed the existence of a
cluster linked to the facility on july
9th four days before hani tested
positive for kovit
politicians blame st micro for the
deaths of more than a dozen workers
between june and july
[Music]
by the
company
the delta variant was ravaging the
country then most of malaysia was locked
down but authorities granted exemptions
to chip makers as it tried to balance
the country's health and economic risks
where are we in the chip shortage now
we're not out of it so it's really a
demand store we have a shortage yes we
do we need more capacity in the industry
the world was facing a microchip
shortage disrupting production of
everything from iphones and f-150
pickups to nike sneakers
st micra was facing extra pressure from
politicians who grew alarmed that the
shortages were shutting down factories
the malaysia semiconductor industry
association argued that it had to do its
part to address the crunch
malaysia accounts for 13
of the world's chip testing and
packaging
nancy's family mourns for the loss of
honey
the couple met at the factory more than
20 years ago
during the pandemic they set up a food
bank near their local mosque to help
those
[Music]
on the day that hani died the government
ordered st micro to shut for a week
[Music]
the company has offered nancy
compensation of about 20 000
which includes 10 months of honey's
basic salary a death allowance and a
life insurance payout
her four children will get about 120 a
month each until they turn 20. st micro
has declined bloomberg's request for an
interview a spokesman said the company
is supporting the families of our
colleagues who passed away due to covet
19 with a comprehensive financial
package which includes a number of
things which are standard across the
company globally as well as specific
measures taking into account the
situation of our employees in muar
notably support for the education of the
children of those families affected
but nancy says it's too little too late
yesterday
[Music]
nancy says there are others like her
who've kept quiet
but she's speaking out
[Music]
it's okay
[Music]